the winner of the $1,000,000 and the
star of the headline show in Las Vegas
is
[Music]
[Applause]
Simon Cowell was just as shocked by
Wednesday season finale of America's Got
Talent
as the rest of us I couldn't believe it
et caught up with the judge after the
show where he got candid about his
golden buzzer pick Michael Keller errs
elimination leaving the competition is
Michael
That moment when Courtney and Michael
came out I went what nice yeah
one of yous not in the child fight I
couldn't believe it
[Applause]
I mean the booze after he was eliminated
I mean I was shot that doesn't happen
the owners like you know who cares but
this time note Ketterer brought down the
house with an emotional rendition of the
courage to love a song written just for
him by Garth Brooks
[Music]
then you gotta
[Music]
and despite cowls disappointment he says
he is happy for this year's winner
magician Shin Lim Shin I have to tell
you last night was the best II had to be
I mean his performance was magical
literally and he's a nice guy but my
heart of course was with Michael but
he's got a future ahead a bright future
I heard on TV today yeah I really really
do and everyone in that in that theater
tonight was rooting for him regardless
of the show's outcome Cal has high hopes
for all of the finalists but whatever
happens I think for most of the people
in the top 10 you know it's an
experience which most people will
benefit from you know you get in front
of this many people you know you've
become known all over the world you know
it's called it was a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]